hello readers there's a famous japanese
movie from 1950 called rashomon which is
about different perspectives on a
horrible crime scene this is a film for
adults definitely consult your parent or
guardian but in the film you witness
four distinct accounts from four
separate people and each person
remembers what happened very differently
the stories contradict each other and by
the end of the film it's still not
completely clear who did what to whom
now this raises an interesting
philosophical question
what is the truth
how does a person's perspective their
point of view their background and their
beliefs change the way they interpret
events or ideas
as readers it's our job to engage with
that question by reading and
synthesizing multiple accounts of events
when we read multiple accounts we grow
closer to understanding a fuller picture
of what happened now we've talked before
about the distinction between first-hand
and second-hand accounts so in 1912 the
titanic sank someone who was aboard and
survived to tell their story has a first
hand account a historian who writes an
account of the titanic has a second hand
account and can incorporate multiple
perspectives
but even among the first hand accounts
you can have wildly different stories
compare someone who was working in the
ship's boiler room to a rich passenger
in a fancy suite they would have had
very different experiences of surviving
or not surviving a shipwreck and it's
important to get in a range of
perspectives in order to get that full
picture
if you've ever watched any kind of
sports game you've probably seen an
argument like this
that's a baseball player arguing with an
umpire umpires and referees have one
perspective on a sports game you were
out and the players have another i was
safe
they both saw the same event the same
play but they see it differently because
their perspectives are so different
now we can take this understanding to
the texts that we read who's the author
of a text what's their perspective and
what informs that perspective the
baseball player wants to be declared
safe the umpire wants to adhere to the
rules as strictly as possible but maybe
they're also an umpire that likes to
call players out because they like
having that power over people
let's go back to the example of the
crime scene from the beginning of the
video
imagine there's been a car crash now
below are two different accounts of the
same crash
from the driver's perspective i was
driving along hands on the wheel eyes on
the road when suddenly out of nowhere
this kid on a bike comes racing out in
front of me i swerved to avoid them and
ran my car into this tree it's the
biker's fault my car is wrecked now
here's the cyclist's perspective i was
biking along in the bike lane when i
look over and this driver is texting not
looking where they're going they were
weaving into the bike lane so i moved
out into the road to keep from being hit
they must have panicked because they
crashed their car right into a tree i'm
lucky the driver didn't hit me they
should pay attention when they drive
same situation very different
perspectives now if only we had an
additional eyewitness to tell us what
they saw that might clear things up
the more accounts you have the more
confident you can feel in the accuracy
of the facts
so ask yourself who's writing the text
are they a fancy passenger on a cruise
ship or are they shoveling coal in the
boiler room are they a baseball player
or a baseball umpire it is only by
comparing multiple accounts that will
get to the bottom of things
you can learn anything
dave it out